the year 2000
when the world witnessed the birth of
one of the first live simulation games
this was the game where everything was
possible
where you were the true master of your
character's destiny
the sims
sam played it well some not so much
along with the game a language was
created sinlish
and although the sims weren't real their
voices weren't real humans were in
charge of recording possibly the world's
most famous fictional language
fun
humans like syrian scot
swaby
[Applause]
if you ever find yourself in redwood
city at the electronic arts headquarters
keep an ear out for something that
sounds like
[Music]
this
bar
sweet floyma
that's simlish the fictional language
for the sims all sorts of scenarios are
recorded as the characters in the game
are just like us
they get married
yes
oh yeah
oh love you to god let some go
[Music]
oh
the language is universal and it's
pretty much loved worldwide
the sims was created in the late 1990s
by will writes and it first hit the
gaming shelves in the year 2000.
the game had all sorts of players we had
the avid home decorators some who
couldn't wait to see the grim reaper
and some just wanted to cheat
you know who you are money and behind
all that action there was a language
that helped you play you could
understand it but not quite speak it
yeah i played the game for
hundreds of hours i think
no one knows simlish better than claire
curtin who was the audio director on the
first version of the sims we knew that
we wanted to just do one language sound
for the whole game that would work for
the whole world so we experimented with
several languages thinking that we could
scramble them in some way so that they
wouldn't be so recognizable and so
repeatable
one of them was navajo asha
and we also had some experimentation
with ukrainian dwarf
i think we also considered estonian
dukes cox calm nelly
one of the reasons why it didn't really
gel was that it still got written out
when you read it's repetitive claire's
team needed something that wouldn't bore
players and that would feel universal so
they turned to improvisation
and it was effective i mean we all knew
what this meant
we would do
30 takes of
two
sims having an interaction and the
actors would do it differently every
single time so every phrase was
different from the one before it
at the time only 10 to 15 words were set
and 20 years later those words are still
part of the game for example
yes
no me valk persegoplerv
you see like a couple of seconds of what
this sim is doing
there's a emotion behind it there's a
personality with it you're feeling super
shocked and then you're feeling lots of
pain
wow
oh gooby lava
[Music]
it feels really freeing to record in
english or speaking simlish because
there's no ties to the meanings of words
so you could be as raw and emotional as
you want it's a great challenge and it's
a lot of fun to
to create something out of nothing in a
way whoa oh you're bleak sir julia
to fleeb
to flutie
to phleb that's that's how you die in
sim
it's not just a game that's popular in
this city or in this culture or i mean
it's a worldwide phenomenon and i get
emails and questions from people all
over the world
sometimes in languages i don't even
understand and i just write back go soul
soul dag dag zeba corbett
we never knew that the game was going to
take off the way it did it's very
gratifying that it worked
oh
[Music]